conseils de classe des cherry et
géraldine maillet ma chérie c'est tout
ça n'était pas une photo souvenir
voilà ce que pensent de vous tous les
chroniqueurs les cherry et je viens
d'avoir un sms et beaucoup de toute
hausse me dise petite info il paraît
dans le charmant casting 10 berjamin
castaldi a les yeux ouverts aux non
c'est vrai mais je vous jure plus que
d'habitude avec un trucage puisque c'est
vrai ouais c'est bonheur peut-être
l'exemple c'est peut-être la douleur
exactement qu'est ce qu'a fait mal très
mal aux doigts
ah oui oui bon d'accord j'ai mal aux
doigts j'ai l'oeil qui s'ouvre puisque
la vengeance monte avant le lancement
ouais ça fait cinq ans qu'on l'attend là
à laisser partir l'un des films à voir
et c'est parti pour le conseil de classe
de géraldine maillet une élève intellos
qui emploie des mots que même le prof ne
semble pas tout à fait comprendre
on se sent un peu et brieuc et brio va
bien voilà on est brillant mais si côté
bécherel elle met à l'amande le dirlo
pas de doute elle a bien compris qui
mettait les notes pour géraldine il ya
deux génies balzac et baba ah ouais moi
vous avez vous êtes vous est
métamorphosé vous sentez toujours bon et
devrait comprendre un petit peu votre
méthode de d'hygiène en fait il faut
mériter même la première place tous les
jours dans mon cas
bref géraldine une élève modèle qui n'a
pas sa langue dans sa poche
pour moi c'est une mascarade de deux
pantins qui sent mal de buzz doc chez
vous tuez l'ont tué endormi je m'emballe
est que geforce intersidéral alors
quelle note pour géraldine géraldine
mallet vous attendez surtout celle de
classe et bien sûr vous réagissez vous
donne également vous aussi une note
agira lui ai dit on va commencer par
jimmy et juste après on fera mohamed ali
toumi alors géraldine tu partages autant
le sens de l'adar cas que l'époque des
neuf n'ont pas fait de chirurgie
esthétique
tu oublie parfois que tpm pc une
émission d'automne et qu'on n'est pas en
deuxième ou troisième partie de soirée
avec ppda pour un public de plus de 65
ans et tu te sens obligé même quand on
demande ton avis sur danse avec les
stars de placer des mots compliqués ou
des références littéraires et finalement
on sait que la culture c'est comme la
confiture plus létal mois on en a je me
dis que tu serais un peu plus épanouie
pour lire les livres à 4 heures du matin
qu'axel witsel entre 4h et 6h ce que
celle qui lit les livres et malgré tout
j'oublie pas et ça seul et sincère et
réel que tu es celle qui m'a aidé avant
que je vienne ici et c'est grâce à toi
que j'ai pu écrire un livre n'a pas
hésité à m'aider alors que oui et non
c'est vrai c'est vraiment de lire tes
pmp c'est grâce à toi que j'ai pu écrire
un livre chez flammarion donc vraiment
merci du raffut de mettre la moyenne
mais comme j'étais moquer de la
moustache de valérie acquis il ya deux
jours les saynètes de mettre quatre sur
dix parce qu'on touche pas avaler
[Applaudissements]
alors c'était quoi le site à vos clients
en attendant le docteur g prenait
attendant le signal chez moi j'ai adoré
ce livre c'est l'impasse vous l'avez
offert je sais je les termine à calais
rue ranger lui justement en attendant le
docteur là j'ai lu tous les livres de
mes compatriotes braiment tous
oui moi aussi j'ai lu votre livre combat
d'insultés ce n'est pas insulter c'est
mal parlé de moi d'avoir les pas du tout
j'ai dit que j'étais tyrannique qui ici
peut dire le contraire mais il est fou
mais non vous n'êtes pas musicien
jean-michel doit pas du tout mais alors
là vous êtes un ange en revanche quand
je vous ai appelé pour votre livre vous
et moi pas du tout mais pour qui tu
prends toi on va régler ça jeudi
prochain lors du prime c'est chaoui
tient visiblement à non à la plus douce
la plus attentionné et de bons conseils
et tu sais trouver mes mots quand moi je
ne les ai pas et non mais sincèrement
c'est vrai et vraiment je t'adore j'ai
rien préparé parce que je savais que
j'allais parler avec le carnot et du
coup je te mets un 8 sur 10
allez c'est vrai que l'amérique et
librado
et khedira d'une très belle phrase avis
j'ai rien préparé parce que je savais
que j'allais parler avec le coeur j'ai
rien préparé surtout parce que j'avais
c'était la vraie la halle la vraie fin
de la phrase merci voilà merci
allez on va donner la parole à isa elle
n'est pas venue seule elle est venue
avec mort signé avec bosque également
alors il ya belle
allez-y alors ma géraldine en pointe un
point commun avec géraldine c'est que
moi aussi je trouve daniel riolo trt 6 x
2 minutes par là à la productrice que et
les invités rentreront après la pub
merci aux filles merci donc en a point
commun géraldine et moi ma gérald ils
ont tous les deux gagné le riolo très
sexy mais elle elle connaît son sujet de
l'intérieur mais nettement mieux que moi
aime bien sûr que je vais lui même sait
lire écrire et parler mais nous aussi
donc c'est pas pour ça que j'aime le
plus j'aime géraldine parce qu'elle est
bienveillante brillante vivante
vaillante très vaillante
bref tout ce qu'elle savait la passion
qui comprit bandante est donc c'est pour
ça que j'aime beaucoup je rappelle qu'on
doit déjeuner d'ici peu de temps et donc
bref je l'aimais je lui met huit le
conseil de classe de germanie vous avez
été formidables tous les deux alors on
était suzanne en fait c'est fait alors
christine kelly alors
ma note dans un instant point faible je
dirais captait pas très dark a mais on
prend bien vrai nom mais parfaitement
très très bien m donc six points faibles
en point positif qui a toujours deux des
analyses de bonnes positions tu es
magnifique aussi est très belle et très
posé et surtout tu sais tenir tête aussi
parfois quand on tue en contradiction
avec baba et pour tout ça je te félicite
et je te mets insectes bon géraldine
c'est la plus maline d'entre nous un
éclairement ici elle s'est égarée dans
une classe de soudou et on va pas se
mentir pour toi prévaut de gaz est clair
et et c'est vrai que je t'aime beaucoup
tu es intelligent parfois il est mou je
sais pas ce qu'on voit pas toujours mais
pour tous et bonne raison
ce que tu es l'élément modérateur de
l'émission je te mets un magnifique huit
[Applaudissements]
meilleurs amis donc que te dire tu es
brillante au laurie non mais il a assuré
qu à noter que la meilleure affiche mais
notez la chroniqueuse que briand tué
cultiver tu as surtout une valeur que je
mets au dessus de tout tu es droite dans
ses bottes
tu ne dévie pas y compris lorsque tu es
toi lorsque tu es seul à avoir une
pensée
peu importe que le groupe essaie de
faire pression peu importe que les
moutons de panurge je te dise il faut
aller dans ce sens là si tu veux prendre
une autre direction tu l'apprends et
tête haute et par ailleurs tu ne fuit
jamais eu vent des barrières la moldavie
exactement on l'a vu ces derniers jours
tu n'as pas fui les débats bien au
contraire et tu étais vraiment présente
et rien que pour ça je te trouve
formidable tu affrontes ou toujours peu
importe la tempête on me tuer sans faux
semblants et évidemment ton seul petit
ivan hoareau enfin petit défaut c'est
mon ami je dis ce que je veux quand je
veux comme je veux
un petit défaut c'est qu'effectivement
parfois tu ne veux pas faire de manning
parce que parce que tu as tu crois que
tu n'es pas d'arc alors que tu me
lèverai
mais on annonce jean michel maire alors
maintenant
gérad et je pourrais évidemment dire que
tu as intelligente drôle cultivé que tu
as le courage de ses opinions et tu as
des analyses médias traitent souvent
très pertinent je pourrai mais je n'ai
aucune envie
voilà ça pleut bonne raison que quand je
te vois en face de moi je n'arrive pas à
voir que la fille qui m'a foutu un
râteau la dernière de rentrer sans terre
exactement
alors comme je suis très rock unis en
plus évidemment tu ne mérites pas de
cette note
mais pour une fois ça me fait très
plaisir de te la mettre tous les deux
merci mathieu géraldine quand on a
décidé il ya un an avec cyril de te
faire venir dans l'émission s'écoute on
s'est dit il faut un pendant en féminin
de ce que je suis il fallait quelqu'un
de beau quelqu'un d'intelligent trancher
dans des débats qui plus est à la fois
dans le show dans le débat et dans
l'intelligence c'est pour ça que tu es
venu en revanche sur le voilà en
revanche il ya trois ans décroît tu ne
l'as pas en revanche tu as dit que tu es
intellectuelle que thé littéraire mais
ça forcément vu la bande de débiles
d'automne à table quand on ne peut pas
verlan apparaît même on respecte le
monde et isabelle jimmy kelly
alors depuis l'avant soir dont je suis
la grande allée de gens qui ne sont pas
également cultivé doc gynéco voilà merci
c'est bien débile amical voilà mais si
ça se trouve dans une vraie émission
culturelle serait d'équilibrer de
belligérance et on sait perroquet libido
venez
alors là c'est mort je vous rappelle
qu'elle a fait btp balances ton post
elle était joli nom et géraldine kelly
ok ça rit l'humour est resté dans les
loges pour toi tu es je vais très vite
elle patineur artistique lamento le qubo
la très très vite et très solide et
intelligent tu as des avis tranchés
c'est vrai que tu ose parfois t'opposer
bon à lui 14 ce qui est pas évident
c'est qu'il en faut
celui qui s est la blonde c'est pas
évident donc bravo pour tout ça
franchement j'ai essayé de trouver des
défauts et n'a pas beaucoup donc le seul
défaut serait que tu pars tu te souhaite
de rester ses neuf escales des lettres
giral et des loyers 5,2 sur 10 7,4 pour
les chroniqueurs 6,3 de moyenne générale
iranienne est ce que tu as passé une
belle année très vite ben moi j'ai
beaucoup de chance j'ai un espace de
liberté incroyable tous les soirs on
s'est beaucoup j'ai peut-être que je
devrais malizé encore plus il a écouté
christine quiniou valérie bénaïm donc
merci d'écouter quand je suis pas
d'accord et voilà et une petite phrase
puisque vous aimez bien les petites
phrases impose ta chance serre ton
bonheur et va vers ton risque à te
regarder ils s'habitueront charles
agence tous risques barak
[Applaudissements]